or we get all the letters on the ground
now from senior intelligence Analyst at
McKenzie intelligence Services Stuart
Ray
um Stuart what do you make of those
comments from President Biden I mean
this is clearly President Biden is
signaling that he's open to negotiate uh
with Moscow but it must be under the
terms of genuinely looking to end the
war for its part Moscow is intimating a
willingness to talk with Washington to
secure its interests that being the key
phrase at this stage President Putin
will not compromise on his aims and he
will not settle for anything short of
securing the recently annexed
territories within Ukraine and it will
continue in his determination to achieve
his military aims uh whatever the cost
anything else really will be politically
dangerous for him domestically in short
what we're seeing here is basically the
gulf between Moscow and the West is far
too great at this time for any
meaningful negotiations to commence
anytime soon all right let's get our map
up here because I want to talk about
what's actually happening on the ground
in in the country reports of Russian
withdrawal rules from supper Asia yeah
we're seeing early reports of some troop
movements withdrawing from the front
line in the zapparicha O blast it's too
early to say at the moment that this is
a concerted withdrawal it's highly
unlikely that we're going to see any
significant change the front line as
we've witnessed in hark Eve and her son
in the complex so far what we're
probably seeing is the the Russian
troops in that area are currently
experiencing severe strikes by the
ukrainians and they're probably falling
back to better prepared defensives to
easily or more easily defend that front
line it's also possible that we're
seeing some re-prioritization of the
troops to secure the defensive buildup
that they're building up in Herson and
also on the offensive that they're
mounting in Donetsk around the Bachman
region let's talk about Hesson if we can
Russian troops withdrawing from there we
didn't think that they were going to go
quietly and we've got some Drone footage
haven't we here that shows pretty
extensive damage along key Bridges
around there yeah I'm the neat Pro River
um is a strategic obstacle for both
sides that splits uh the hair salon
oblaston too and those Crossings of that
River are vitally important to both
sides and what we've seen is ukrainians
targeting them to disrupt the Russian
logistical chains and freedom of
movement so basically to deny them to
the Russians what we're seeing here is
the evidence of the fighting and we're
seeing some particularly bad damage to
to the ground into the infrastructure
this is the kakovka dam it's a
hydroelectric plants we can see the the
trenches and the defensive positions
that were prepared by the Russians which
clearly shows was a sizable Force where
where count out in its location and and
the ukrainians have targeted those and
we could see the devastation and the
Damage that has been brought down onto
the troops in that position there all
right uh Stuart thank you very much
indeed for your analysis